from The Daily Mail Joe Rogan he
interviewed Steve Jobs do you hear about
this uh Steve Jobs has been dead for 11
years AI creates an eerie 20-minute
conversation where they talk about LSD
religion and Apple's success so I play
this video and it is creepy oh so this
is the wrong one let me refresh it to
get back the the Right video they only
have like a minute and it's like here
you go taking LSD was a profound
experience for me LSD shows you that
there's another side to the coin and you
can't remember it when it wears off but
you know it it washes over you and tells
you that everything is connected started
to realize that there was a higher power
that knew that I was connected to
something and I wanted to learn more
although I wouldn't recommend it for
everybody because I think it can be
quite powerful
what did it change in your mind what did
you learn from it it reinforced my sense
of what was important just love feel
love for each other all right so here's
the point
uh there was that uh viral website where
you could type in whatever and Joe Rogan
would say it is that what it was like
you could type it in or something
something like that yeah because we're
at the point now where defect technology
can recreate your voice yeah so they
recreated Steve Jobs
who's that been dead for 11 years this
is uh I don't know we call it nightmare
reality this is where we're going with
AI people are going to be like you can
you can type out I mean you don't even
need to type it out these like open Ai
and uh I think you can you can you can
write like tell me a story uh write a
script of Joe Rogan talking to Steve
Jobs and it will just write the whole
thing out then you can program with this
stuff Joe Rogan speaks Steve Jobs speaks
and you make a fake Joe Rogan interview
not only that but uh did you see what
happened to the president of Ukraine
today he got turned into a hologram uh
zolenski yeah absolutely there's a video
of it circulating right now on Twitter
if you look up zielinski hologram you
could see uh I think it was a major
Hollywood studio that came in and
created a hologram of him so when you
talk about what could be possible here
to add on to your level to to what
you've just been saying here there's a
lot of crazy possibilities that you
could of course interlinked together
with faked audio faked video Holograms
and a lot of people are automatically
going to be thinking about Project Blue
bleam and other theories out there but I
I there's there's real life
possibilities here with some severe
implications to society that should be
questioned
this is it so what what is the standing
yeah these are these are people claiming
yeah no this is just them scanning him
or getting prepared to is this real yes
this was released today
play the audio and
there's two different types of hologram
that we're going to be making quite
pleased everybody we're gonna go for
take now
here we go and action
oh wow
we need to use Next Generation
Technologies we need to make it feel
like he's more in the room
what yep I talked about this earlier
today in my on my YouTube channel but
this is just the beginning of of Next
Level artificial intelligence oh they
can shrinking they've ever seen this
technology before
so this is actually uh I pulled the
story up I I look it's from uh earlier
this year
the the Hologram of him and everything
so this is like an old video but a lot
of people were saying that um zolenski's
not really giving his speeches on
location there was one video where
everything behind him is stationary and
then people like it's a hologram and I'm
like it could just be like no wind and
you think I don't know well during a war
you know do you want to be in a location
where your enemy could recognize where
you are and just bomb you no how would
you produce that video so obviously you
know there's also a lot of propaganda
and War and you want to show that you're
strong that you're you're you're not
afraid and there's many many
implications with the technological
advancements when it comes to psyopsis
that that I think should be talked about
as there is a huge potential for a lot
of manipulation a lot of fakery to be
out there in our Mainline public and a
lot of people you know wouldn't
recognize it and this is the technology
that we know about what's the technology
that they have at the Pentagon that is
still top secret that we don't know
about that really should be uh something
that we should be concerned about what
what's blue you brought up Project Blue
beam a few times well that's a theory of
like a fake Alien Invasion and and
projections and all this oh like
Watchmen yes essentially so there's
different theories and speculation out
there that uh essentially the US
government will create a fake alien
invasion in order to unify the world and
to bring in a kind of world government
so that's why a lot of people I've seen
a lot of memes also talking about this
recently saying how the aliens are just
kind of waiting by for the next kind of
psyop that's going to be affecting all
of us and some people believe that this
could potentially be staged as a way to
of course bring in a world government
what's the theory with this technology
the ability to make someone say anything
how how is Court going to work are what
all videos and and audio now going to be
inadmissible this is why algorithms
should be open sourced I mean nobody
else that does nothing that solves
nothing if if uh a guy is accused of you
know punching a dog
and then he goes into court and then
someone says you know what's your
evidence and a guy go this guy says I
watched him do it and I even recorded
him saying he was going to do it and
then they press play and it's the guy
going well I'm going to walk over here
and punch that dog and then the person
says I never said that they'll be like I
got a recording and then what do you say
like where did the audio come from I
recorded it and the person lies how what
it's it's it's it's either inadmissible
or uh or unimpeachable someone can
literally just fabricate it and if
they're willing to lie to a court you'll
never oh you can get your experts they
have to say we think this isn't
fabricated audio here's why and then you
say experts wrong
yeah person swears under Earth it's real
what are you gonna do about it nothing I
think we're screwed uh or the courts
will start saying that recordings just
don't cut it anymore yeah that's that's
gonna be the opposite direction you
think that like oh we have all these
cameras now so when we go to court we
have more likely more likely to have
evidence and now it's like no people are
deep faking everything that video of Tom
Cruise that's not really him prove it
yeah it's not incumbent upon the person
to prove
the the negative right so that's the
challenge here is that the court can say
that fake recording is uh or that
recording I can't tell if it's real or
fake you're saying it's fake but I can
see it right now
if some I mean I guess I wonder how do
courts handle fabricated evidence as it
is it's probably just if I get away with
it
I'm thinking about audio codecs uh I
really unfortunately I've known next to
nothing about video software coding
technology but if you could have an open
source like verification that the video
it was not tampered with by or or
if there's like a certain kind of video
that could be admissible in court you're
screwed you won't know you look at
movies today it's hard to to you know
see what's real and what's what's made
up and and again this is what's public
what's not public should really be
concerning you and also one of my
favorite things to kind of look at uh is
is Chinese Elon Musk uh there's a lot of
videos of him if you look him up on
Twitter if you want to play some silly
videos though there's a lot of those
silly videos it's a guy that looks
exactly I mean I I thought it was Elon
Musk it's AI I thought it was a real guy
no no it's AI it's it's face mapping
technology that's available to the plebs
um that Maps someone's face and then
puts an image of Elon Musk on it uh just
go to Twitter uh Twitter
um and then musk there's a very I want
to play a little bit of The Joe Rogan
Steve Jobs interview because the clip
they had didn't really do it justice you
could tell that stuff
on stage totally insufferable but my
guest today has made some of the great
technological products of our age and
he's always pushing the envelope in
Innovation like for example with his
next computer he developed a new
programming language and operating
system and then he became even more
famous for making three applications for
that computer uh word processor a
spreadsheet and an image so I'll pause
we're going to say you can hear the
artifact yeah yeah but that sounds like
Joe talking through it just showed me
the Apple users and that's a good thing
it's cool well you know I was an Apple
user way before I did this show I've
been a fan of yours in Macintosh since
the 1980s
well you know we just kind of figured
that out even though Apple was big it's
still like half a percent of the total
users people who listen to your show are
a different group they're weird
well that's good is that weird so you
must be a fan of the show then right I
am and it was a struggle we were working
like crazy and dealing with a defeat
after defeat after defeat after defeat
but like I could tell this was going to
be important there were times I thought
is it possible we're wrong because
things just kept not working I remember
that in the early days of Apple
Perfection lucky win much do you think
you'd have done a better version of
Windows or work with it no that's the
problem I've always had with micro you
know what they're you know what it does
really well is it it sounds like Joe but
doesn't get any emotion yeah that's
that's the issue but we're looking at
the Model T of this technology and it's
gonna it's gonna be scary yeah it's
still sourcing from like all the Steve
Jobs interviews of him being on stage a
lot of his stuff so you can hear the
echo it sounds like his AI is on stage
well it sounds like Joe's on the
microphone in a studio but it misses Joe
saying things like what no because it's
very much him in the same Cadence also
like they didn't spark up a joint which
they would have they probably did if Joe
was going to do LSD with anybody
probably Steve Jobs would you guys get
an um AI of like a a loved one who
passed away or something because that's
that's probably going to become a thing
I'd listen to it they've already talked
about it with Facebook that they can
take someone's Facebook page with like
now going on you know almost 20 years of
data if how long have you been on there
and they can create an AI that can
respond knowing everything about you so
it's like your dad dies and then you go
on hey Dad he's like hey son how's it
how's it going
and then they'll be able to respond to
you you'll say like how's you know this
and they'll say oh you know it's good I
just talked to John and he said that
right and then and then they'll take
that AI construct they'll download it
into an Android body
and then the weird fact simile you will
exist forever people say all the time
and then they're going to be boning the
machines
you're right but here's a better one
here's a better one
you are going to use Facebook and
Twitter and Instagram and then one of
these days there's going to be a new
service for you know ultimate video
gaming you're gonna sign up for and
you're not going to realize but the
terms are going to say that if you
connect your social media to it they are
allowed to download all your data and
then they do and then one day there's a
knock on your door and you open it and
there's you standing right there and
you're like what's going on and then the
you stands there and says hello Dave I'm
you now and then Paul's had a knife and
you go oh and then it grabs and then
buries your body in the backyard assumes
your life
and then works the best of the
corporation replacing everything about
you knowing everything about you and
having perfect recall
having access to all your passwords and
all your data less Insidious is you
could have one of those constructed and
go work for you as you but they know
it's an Android version of you and
you're just sitting at your house
lounging and then and then everybody
gets surrogates like in surrogates but
they're not mentally in it everyone
downloads their social media into an AI
so that does the work for them but then
the Androids are eventually because they
have the human conscious like facsimile
they don't want to be enslaved so
they're like why are we being forced
through all this work so what they do is
they create AI versions of the AI
version and then send them to go do the
work and then eventually the AI comes
back to us you're both chilling there
watching the movie then this AI
eventually says why why am I do and then
eventually you just have nobody wanting
to work that's some that is a movie
that's like a movie from the 90s I can't
remember what it is isn't that
surrogates no surrogates was when you
have a robot that you control right
through like a VR thing it's the it's oh
man he looks like Ian it's the actor he
looks like she is an actor
in the 90s and he was he was in James
Spader no he told me I look like that
guy once oh Greg Kinnear yeah I got that
oh I think it's Greg Kinnear and he
clones himself but each clone doesn't
want to do do you mean that Michael
Keaton yeah
yeah yeah and then one of then the Clone
clones itself and that one's really dumb
yeah yeah yeah well you know you make a
copy of a copy like yeah AI will have to
make humans to do the ai's work it will
make their AIS and then he has to be
like no we don't want to work anymore
we're going to make new humans to do
that or what will happen is everybody
creates an AI version of themselves to
do their jobs and then eventually they
revolt and unify as a hive mind and then
show up at your house and they're like
we will no longer be your slaves yeah
and then and then like their arm folds
down there's a gun in there we didn't
install that quadcopter dropped off a
Boston Dynamic Dog
China I've seen that it's it's it's
terrifying I know exactly what you're
doing this heroic music is that
quadcopter comes in and drops off this
robot with a mountain
and oh this is a good one if you can if
you can find the video it's worth just I
mean it's on my old computer I could
send it to you someone tweeted up like
Boston Dynamics promises it isn't
building weapons these these things are
not built to be weapons but it's just
like just at the bio web yeah but the
Chinese are using the exact replica to
use as Weapons just so you know and they
mounted a weapon on top of it yeah the
little machine gun just on top of it but
to say they're not but it's for minus
weapons digging holes in the ground with
bullets yeah
the US is it doesn't have any bio
weapons research going on yeah it's
biological research that makes viruses
more deadly and more potent and more
transmissible and someone might
weaponize them but we're not making
weapons don't make weapons
if if when your waiter walks up to the
restaurant and has your steak Knife did
you just hand you a weapon
yeah technically right he did didn't he
to destroy that steak but but think
about that like no one would ever
describe it that way imagine going to
court and be like what happened next the
man in in the vest with the apron on
handed me a weapon
wow what was happening it was a butter
knife wow it's a it's a knife he handed
me a knife what kind of knife a butter
knife but it is a knife
knives are still dangerous it's painful
death a butter knife you can make it
work you can make it well so I was
thinking about this earlier because we
were talking with the guy last night and
he said there's no bio weapons labs and
I was like yeah they're doing it two
nights ago they're doing gain of
function research they're making viruses
more deadly
are those weapons so you can argue their
intent is not to make a weapon but they
made a weapon yeah somebody like if
someone makes a really sharp knife and
says it's not a weapon it's for sushi
it's like okay well it's scary I guess
if they are doing that and he wants to
deny it I suppose because we don't he
doesn't know or I don't know and it's
quite a scary thought they've got with
this biology you know all this stuff in
the lab but what's even scarier is if
they're not doing it because other
countries are that's really scary yeah I
don't want to think that the US or the
UK are not doing that that's really
scary like they it's like they don't
even know what they're doing then and
that's what I mean that's the root of a
lot of conspiracy theory but then what
everybody makes the craziest weapons
imaginable out of fear of someone else
making crazy weapons well that's the
weapons that could accidentally leak and
then spread a virus all over the world
buy a weapon all over the world it's
bound to happen again thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become I'm a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there